[Music]
Oh.
Oh,
[Music]
Peace TV, the solution for humanity.
La
[Music]
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la
[Music]
[Applause]
Brothers and sisters, it is indeed a
fantastic
opportunity
to see such a lovely gathering
at this mega event peace for humanity.
When this whole concept was conceived,
it was only a dream which has now been
realized thanks to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. The response is phenomenal.
Imagine such a big Muslim festival for
10 days. How often do we get an
opportunity like this to gather all
Muslim and non-Muslim brothers and
sisters under one roof?
Indeed, we are fortunate and we should
be thankful to Allah for giving us such
an opportunity.
In today's world scenario, we feel that
there is a need for promoting better
ideals amongst the youth.
Whether one is a follower of Islam or
any other religion, it is essential to
know the ultimate power on earth. As I
belong to the religion of Islam, I
thought this is my duty to bring the
youth of today to know not only the
ideals of the religion but also the need
to live with communal harmony for the
good of the world as a whole. In order
to know about the religion for communal
harmony, one is to be educated to the
utmost. This event is purely for
communal harmony, is for awareness and
it is for education.
I request brother Ashra to give the bada
of brother Zakinak before he starts his
lecture. Shukran. Dr. Zakin Nak is a
medical doctor by professional training
but he's an internationally acclaimed
aator on Islam and comparative religion.
He clarifies and clears misconceptions
about Islam using Quran, authentic
hadith, and other religious scriptures
which he quotes verbitim in conjunction
with reason, logic, and scientific
facts. He's popular for his critical
analysis and convincing answers to
challenging questions posed by audiences
worldwide. After his public talks, he
has delivered public talks in the USA,
Canada, UK, Saudi Arabia, UAE,
Australia, South Africa, Botswana,
Malaysia, Singapore, Hong Kong,
Thailand, Guyana, South America and many
other countries in addition to numerous
other talks in India.
She shik Ahmed Dat the world famous
aator on Islam and comparative religion
has called Dr. Dr. Zak and Nyak did
theat plus Dr. Zakin Nyak appears
regularly on many international TV
channels in more than 150 countries of
the world. More than 100 of his talks,
dialogues, debates and symposia are
available on DVD. He has authored
several books on Islam and comparative
religion. I present before you brothers
and sisters Dr. Zach and I will speak on
the topic the purpose of creation.
Alhamdulillah
the respected people on the my respected
elders and my dear brothers and sisters.
I welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings. Assalamu alaykum.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala of almighty God be
on all of you.
The topic of this evening's talk is the
purpose of creation.
This question
what is the purpose of creation
arises in the mind of every individual
sometime or the other.
Irrespective whether he's rich or poor,
king or popper, black or white, yellow
or brown, whether he lives in America or
UK, whether he lives in India or Saudi
Arabia, this question sometime or the
other crops up in the mind of each and
every individual.
Why have we been created? Why are we
here? What is our purpose in this world?
And most of the human beings they think
that there has to be a supreme creator
that is almighty god and because of him
we are here. However, there is a
minority who do not believe in the
existence
of the creator of almighty god and they
assume that the full world has come into
existence by chance and we human beings
too we have come into being by chance.
Suppose you see on the beach the
footprints of a human being. Immediately
a logical person he thinks that these
footprints have been created
by the walking of a person.
A logical person will not assume that
the footprints came into existence by
chance or the footprints came into
existence by the waves coming on the
beach and when the waves went away it
created these footprints. A logical
person will realize that these
footprints have been created by a
person. It had a purpose why it was
created.
This question what is the purpose of
creation
can be answered in two perspectives.
Number one from the perspective of the
creator
that is almighty god and second by the
perspective of the creation that is
human being. The first perspective is
the view of the creator almighty god.
What caused him to create the human
being? what caused him to create these
creation and number two from the
perspective of the creation that the
human beings that why were we created by
almighty god.
Those people who do not agree in the
existence of almighty god and believe
that we have come in this world by mere
chance. According to this philosophy,
there is no difference between the human
beings and all the other creation. All
have come by chance. Even the human
beings as well as the animals.
So these people do not have a particular
purpose in life at all. They don't have
a purpose for existence
and
they live the same way as the animals.
Drink, sleep, rest and procreate. That's
it. So the purpose of the animals and
the human beings become the same. To
eat, to drink, to rest, to sleep, and to
procreate.
And because they don't have a purpose,
they try and strive excellence in
eating, in drinking, in living.
And they become materialistic. And
that's the reason for such people
materialism becomes a god. And because
of this, these same people, they create
drugs just to earn money to have a
better living. They create bombs and
weapons of m destruction.
They involve in fornication, in
adultery, in homosexuality, in
pornography. It doesn't make a
difference to them whether they make
drugs or whether they involve themselves
in pornography. The main purpose is just
nothing but materialism. Let us discuss
today the answer
to this question. What is the purpose of
creation from both point of view? First
we'll discuss from the creator's point
of view from the point of view of
almighty god from the point of view of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. What caused
him to create the human beings?
Allah subhanaa says in the Quran in
surah kafir chapter number 40 verse
number 57
that the creation of the heaven and the
earth are far greater than the creation
of the human beings but most of the
human beings here they realize it not
many human beings feel that we are the
greatest of the creation
but Allah says that the creation of the
heaven and the earth is far greater than
the creation of the human beings
and In reply to this query
that why Allah subhanana wa ta'ala why
almighty God created us one of the
attributes of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
of almighty god is the creator the best
creator and Allah says in the Quran
in surah mmun chapter number 23 verse
number 14 that Allah subhanana wa tala
almighty god is the best to create if
there is a creator if his attribute is
creator. There has to be a creation.
If there's no creation, then there
cannot be a creator.
For example,
if you call a person as the best writer,
but naturally you'll ask him that where
is the material you have written? Where
is the book you have written? Where is
the article you have written? So when he
presents the article or the book, then
we can say fine, he is the best writer.
Similarly, since one of the attributes
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is the
creator, the best creator, he has to
have a creation.
But that does not mean that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is dependent on his
creation.
Allah says in the Quran in surah zumar
chapter number 39 verse number 62 that
is Allah subhanana wa ta'ala who creates
everything
and he's independent of all his
creation.
He is not dependent on these things but
the creations are dependent on Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. The Arabic word for
creator is kalik and to create the
Arabic word is kalaka.
Kalaka can divided into two types. One
meaning of kalak is to create
something from something which besides
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala even we human
beings and other creation can do for
example a carpenter
who creates a chair and a table with the
help of wood and nails
but the wood has been obtained from the
trees which has not been created by the
carpenter not Not by human beings but by
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. The nails
have been obtained from metal which have
been obtained from rock which again is a
creation of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
So all the creations done by human
beings they're dependent on basic
elements all of which have been created
by Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. So this
type of creation to create something
from something is a limited type of
creation.
The ultimate and the true creation is to
create something from nothing. And this
no one besides Allah subhanaa tala can
do to create something from nothing.
This is the ultimate creation which none
of the creation can do except the
uncreated Allah subhanana wa ta'ala who
is the creator of all the creation.
Since his attribute
is the creator there has to be creation.
There are various attributes given in
the Quran. For example, he's called as
alman, al rafir,
the merciful, the kind, the forgiver.
The creation of the human beings is a
unique creation.
We human beings, we have a free will of
our own. We can either obey our creator
almighty god or we can disobey. It is a
unique creation.
And because we have this ability to
either obey or disobey our creator, we
can even sin. We can sin. And only
because the human beings can sin can the
quality of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala as
being the forgiver, being kind, being
merciful
can be known. If human beings, if we did
not have a free will and if we had
followed everything what Allah has
commanded, there would be no difference
between us and the angels. The angels
are a creation of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala who do not have a free will of
their own. They obey each and every
commandment of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
because they don't have a free will of
their own. But the human beings have a
free will
and because of this free will
the mercy of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
the kindness of Allah subhanana wa tala
the forgiveness of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala can be known. The other attribute
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala that is
given in the Quran is loving. And Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala says in several
places in the Quran that he loves those
people who trust in him, those people
who are patient, those who are
righteous, those who are pious, those
who are patient and perseverance, those
who approach him and those who trust in
him. And Allah says in the Quran in
surah Almran
chapter number three verse number 31 he
tells to the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. He tells him that tell that if
you love Allah follow me and Allah will
love you and forgive your sins. The
prophet has been commanded by the
creator Allah subhanana wa ta'ala to
tell the people that if you love Allah
you have to follow me that is follow the
prophet and Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
will love you and he will forgive your
sins and there's a hadith of sallallahu
alaihi wasallam mentioned ini and has
been authenticated as sah by shiknas
almani ini
had number 30540
where a beloved prophet wasallam he says
that If you ask Allah, Allah says, if
you approach to me, I will answer you.
And if you ask for forgiveness, I will
forgive you. Even if your sins reach up
to the cloud, I will forgive you. Even
if your sins are as big as a complete
earth, I will approach you. In the same
way with forgiveness as long as you ask
for forgiveness and do not associate
partners with me that means whatever sin
you do as long as you ask for
forgiveness with sincere repentance if
you do not associate partners with Allah
subhanaa tala don't do shik Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala he will forgive you
one of the attributes of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala is the grace and the beloved
prophet wasallam said it's mentioned in
sah Muslim volume number four Hadith
number 6765
where the prophet said that do the right
things do the best deeds to the best of
your ability and be happy.
Do the right things to the best of
ability and be happy
for no one can enter Jenna only on the
basis of his deeds. So one of the sabas
asked that what about you rasool Allah?
So the prophet said not even I
I cannot enter Jenna unless with the
mercy of Allah subhanana wa tala and his
grace unless his grace and mercy and his
forgiveness and will of me I cannot
enter Jenna. So here we realize that
without the grace of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala no one can enter Jenna and Allah
subhananaa tala says in the Quran
in surah anam chapter number six verse
number 160 Allah says that if you do any
good deeds I will multiply it 10 times
into your account and if you do any evil
deed I will only count it as once for
Allah he does not do anything wrong. So
here we realize that if any good deed
you do, Allah subhana says in the Quran,
he will multiply it minimum 10 times
into your account. If you do any evil
deed, he'll count as one. That means if
everyone was accounted one point for his
good deed and one point for his evil
deed without multiplication of the good
deeds, not a single human being would
have entered Jenna. It is the grace of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala that he
multiplies your good deeds and gives you
multiple times more reward that you
shall go to Jenna.
That does not mean that deeds aren't
important. Deeds are very important but
the grace is more important. Without the
grace of Allah you cannot enter Jenna.
Allah multiplies but your deeds also
should be there. If your deed is there
don't even multiply. If your deeds are
zero and if you multiply even million
times it will be useless. So deeds are
also important but without the grace of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala no human being
can enter paradise.
So because of his quality attribute
of being merciful, kind, forgiving,
loving and grace
all these are manifested in the great
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
And one of the attributes is also
supreme justice.
And Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he has in
a gap
before a person is born he knows that
after a person is born whether he'll do
good deeds or bad deeds whether he'll
listen to the commandments of Allah
subhanana wa tala or will he disobey he
knows he even knows whether the person
will go to jannam or ja whether he'll go
to hell or paradise he knows but if
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala moment a
person is born or before he's born he
puts him in heaven person who deserves
heaven and puts the person in hell who
deserves hell
The people who have been put in heaven,
they may not object. They may say fine,
alhamdulillah, we have been put into
heaven, no problem. But surely those
people who have been put in hell, they
will object that how come you haven't
let us lead our life and without a test,
you have put us in hell.
So because Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is
just, Allah says in the Quran in surah
Isa chapter number four verse number 40,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is never
unjust in the least degree. That's the
reason Allah subhanana wa ta'ala lets
the people live in this world
and if you follow the commandments of
Allah subhanana wa tala you pass the
test otherwise you fail the test.
And people may ask that one of the
pillars of im the last pillar escad is
destiny.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah
sagda chapter number 32 verse number 12
Allah says all these people who will go
to hell on the day of judgment. They
will never object to the justice of
Allah subhana wa t'ala. They will say
all the sinners they will bow their head
down and say please forgive us. They
will agree with the Lord. They will say
please give us one more chance
so that we can go again in the world and
that time we will surely be believers.
But Allah knows that even if he forgives
them and puts them back into this world
but natural he'll have to wash out their
memory of what they have seen of the
hell.
Allah is sure that they'll again commit
the same mistake. And this is mentioned
in the Quran in surah Anam chapter
number 6 verse number 28 that if these
people were again sent in the word they
would repeat the same mistakes because
they are liars. So Allah knows in his
divine wisdom that these people even if
he sends them again if the memories
washed out or what they seen of the hell
they will do the same mistakes. But
coming to the question of kad is the
sixth pillar of iman
that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala we
Muslims believe that Allah writes the he
writes the destiny and people may object
many people ask this question Muslims
and non-Muslims alike
that if everything Allah has written in
the destiny that fine whether this
person is going to do good or bad
whether they're going to commit a murder
or whether he's going to commit a rape
or whether he's going to rob or whether
he's going going to do good deeds
whether we're going to go to hell or
heaven if everything is mentioned then
where is our choice who's to blame if I
commit a murder Allah wrote in the I'm
going to commit a murder and I commit a
murders who's to blame Allah is to blame
so why should I be put in hell
and this is a very logical question the
reply to this question is that we have
to understand the concept of kad and
destiny that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
has distined things where a person going
to be born in which condition will be
born. When will he die? Which land will
he die? Allah says in the Quran in surah
is chapter 17 verse number 14 that
whenever a child is born the fat is
bound on his neck. The moment he's born,
Allah knows everything what he's going
to do, good or bad, right or wrong,
whether going to go to hell or heaven.
But Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has ilme
to give you an example that suppose in a
class that the teacher
who teaches about 100 students for about
one year and before the examination
that teacher predicts that this student
he will come out first in class first
class first. this student he'll get
second class that student will fail just
example don't feel bad brother
now
after a few days the examination takes
place and this student comes out first
class first this student gets second
class and that student fails now I'm
asking a question can the student who
failed can you object to the teacher
that because you predicted I'm going to
fail I have failed who's to blame the
teacher or the student who's to blame
the student The teacher predicted this
student he plays hookie he doesn't
attend class he sees movie therefore
he's going to fail that student he's
okay average that student is very
intelligent does good hard work so
teacher predicts in advance before the
examination this student get a first
class first this student second class
that student fail and the student comes
out first class first second class that
student fails but because the teacher
predicted that does not mean the teacher
is to blame the teacher has taught
everyone correctly And equally
similarly Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
he has knowledge of the future certain
thing they are destined he has said that
okay this person born in this land on
this particular date he'll die in this
land in this particular date etc his
surrounding he'll be wealthy or whatever
it is but the choice is yours for
example after you pass your 12th
standard you have a choice of becoming
an engineer or becoming a doctor or
becoming a lawyer
The choice is yours. You choose to
become an engineer. So Allah already
knows in advance that after you pass
your standard 12, you will choose to
become an engineer. He's written in
advance. It is not because Allah has
written that you are choosing.
It is because you have chosen. Allah has
written in advance.
The choice is yours. But Allah knows
your choice. For example, if you come at
a crossroad and there are five roads,
road number 1 2 3 4 5. The choice is
yours. You can either take road number 1
2 3 4 5.
You choose road two. It's already
mentioned in advance in your destiny
that you will choose road two. It is not
because Allah is writing that you're
choosing. It is because you will be
choosing that Allah has written in
advance. So the choice is yours. You
have a choice to earn your living
whether with good deeds halal way or
with robbing haram ways. The choice is
yours. Now you rob.
The choice was yours. But Allah knows in
advance that this person he would want
easy money and he will rob. So Allah has
written in advance that this particular
person at the age of 25 he will rob.
Who's to blame? You are to blame. But
because Allah is in he has written in
advance.
The choice is yours. Allah has given as
human beings free will. You cannot blame
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala for your
misdeeds.
If you go to hell, it is because of your
misdeeds. And if you go to Jenna, it is
because of the grace of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala.
Now let's try and answer this question.
The purpose of creation from a different
angle from the angle of the creation
from the angle from the perspective of
the human being
that why have the human beings being
created by almighty god? And the reply
to this question is given in the Quran
in surah ar chapter number 7 verse
number 172 and verse number 173 Allah
says that he brought out from the loins
of Adam's children may peace be upon him
all the descendants and asked them that
am I your lord and all said we testify
that you are our lord and Allah
continues lest on the day of judgement
ment they will say we were unaware that
you are our lord or lest they may say
that our ancestors
they worshiped somebody else they did
shik they associated partners and we
just followed them so they are the liars
we should not be blamed so Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala before the human
beings came in this world Allah
subhanana wa tala brought all the human
beings from the loins of the children of
Adam and asked them who is the lord and
all of them testified that there's one
Allah subhanana wa tala and he's our
lord
And now is our test in this world. Allah
says in the Quran and I started my talk
by quoting the verse of the Quran from
surah harat chapter number 51 verse
number 56. Allah says that we have
created the jin and the men not but to
worship me.
That we have created the jin and the men
not but to worship me. The purpose of
creation of the human beings and the jin
is to worship Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
Now this word worship
if you analyze this English word it is
derived from the old English vibe which
means to honor and if you read the new
living Webster's encyclopedic dictionary
it says that worship means act of
devotion
honoring the diety
devotional acts honoring the diety
and If you translate into Arabic, the
Arabic word is ibada.
The Arabic word for worship is ibada. It
is derived from the root word abda which
means a slave and it is the duty of the
slave to be obedient to all the wills
and wishes of the master. So ibada means
total submission to the will of the
creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala. Ibada
means total submission to the will and
wishes of the creator Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. And further if you analyze that
even one of the forms of worship as
mentioned in the English dictionary is
glorification.